hi this video aims to bring you some
highlights that Miss coffee been picked
for you from the ACL 2023 conference in
Toronto last week we will show you some
poster sessions and if you're interested
in the second keynote at ACL from
Professor Allison gopnick arguing that
large language models are a cultural
technology check out our last video so
here we are at the ACL 2023 Toronto also
session so we'll have some hopefully
interesting discussions with the authors
and I hope that they will be able to
explain their stuff in simple terms
because you know authors usually tend to
be really experts in saying they have
written about because they have spent at
least a few months if not a year with
the topic or even more so it would be
really great if we can prompt them like
one of our language models to talk in
synthetic terms about the works so let's
see here is some coffee from the future
importantly you can find links to the
papers of the interviewed authors in the
description below as well as their
Twitter profile small disclaimer
unfortunately I do not have a clean
audio track of my questions so I
re-recorded them in post-production
where needed enjoy
foreign
[Music]
is solving some kind of coding problems
which are somewhat similar to interview
problems and big tech companies so
I think that's really characterizes
those problems and make them different
from let's say human eval data set which
is just natural language to code is that
to solve such a problem you don't need
to come up with some sort of an idea
which is not obvious by looking at the
problem statement for instance if you
have a very simple problem
that you have an array of integers with
different signs and you want to check if
it's possible to make this array sorted
just by swapping signs of any two
integers so you can already see that the
Boost Force solution is not feasible for
this problem there are too many
combinations so you need to come up with
some idea and the idea is super simple
is you just need to observe that for
this array to be sorted you need to have
like negative numbers first so you just
need to move negative signs to the
beginning so just count the negative so
apparently the problem that I just
described is not solvable by gpt4 but
this wasn't like three months ago when I
tested it so it means that gpd4 is no
good at competitive level programming
open AI actually has published a result
saying that it has a rating of 392.
which is if you're familiar with chess
ratings you can see that the maximum
rating is around 3K which is like Grand
Master levels and the level of this
problem is around 800 so it's very
simple and GPT has like 400. it means
that it's definitely no good at solving
such as a competitive programmer
yourself how do you feel about these
results and how do you think the
capabilities of large language models
will change in the future iterations
yeah I definitely feel like very
inspired that I can use my prior
experience from high school when I did
that to actually try to improve the
reasoning of large language models I do
think that this type of tasks could be
the kind of next generation of evals for
large language models because right now
everyone is concerned about human eval
which is just generating code from
pretty much detailed instructions with a
little bit of something non-obvious but
it's not on that level but once the
language models improve there will be
definitely some more challenging evals
required and this is definitely very
challenging because you already see that
those models are not good at even
solving like 800 problems so actually
Alpha code developed an approach that
enabled to solve like 1500 rated
problems but the issue is that they
sample huge amount of solutions here we
are talking about sampling 10 solutions
from a language model so if we can wait
if we want to wait at a moment where a
person competing on this website the
code forces can basically cheat and copy
paste the statement to charge GPT and
get correct code it's definitely going
to happen in some time but it's gonna
take some time it's not happening isn't
it a bit ironic that you are working
towards making models better at coding
so you program them to steal your job
kind of I mean when I started doing
research in in language models my
motivation was that someday if I like
stay being like software engineer I
might get replaced and I think
everything is going into this direction
maybe not replaced but I think in 10
years a lot of jobs will be a lot of job
will be done by language models or or
like the descendants of language models
that we don't know but actually there
will be a job of a software engineering
will be definitely different than it is
today
more powerful autocompletes
well maybe but I think also our approach
is like Auto GPT once once those models
gets more powerful like we get more
powerful base models it's gonna do like
crazy stuff like basically it's gonna
write like the entire scripts with like
some very few instructions and yeah it's
gonna boost the productivity which is
nice it's especially useful for
researchers Because deep learning
researchers don't usually like to write
like data pre-processing code and so on
I'm already using when I train large
language models I'm already using gpt4
to generate data pre-processing card
because I'm so lazy aren't you worrying
about putting the tool of programming
into everybody's hands since these
models can code from just descriptions
in natural language I mean there is
something to it like definitely needs
some regulation but on the other hand
it's like
it's just people will be bothered with
with different stuff like with more
difficult conceptual stuff because it's
not obvious how how fast these models
will get better at this tasks like it it
will just shift their work towards
reasoning from coding and I think it's
useful like one of the reasons I don't
want to become a software engineer for
life is that I get pretty bored with
doing this infrastructure and stuff
there's not much of like
once I have like one or two years of
experience I I get bored and actually
I've heard this from so many researchers
that transitions from transition from
software engineering to deep learning
last question do these large language
models understand oh that's that's such
a great question I mean I don't want to
make any any sort of phobia here you
cannot forget that we are at a
Linguistics conference I would say well
I would say it probably doesn't matter
like what people care about is actually
to solve these problems so no matter if
they understand or not they will get
better with time basically people are
even controversial with reasoning like
with first reasoning and I think there
is something to reasoning that makes it
like when I solve these problems in high
school it was really about not about
being super creative but about
memorizing lots of solutions and then
associating those Solutions and like one
of the hypotheses of mine at least like
very kind of high level intuition what
is happening inside large language
models is that they develop such
representations that allow for like
better associations actually so
obviously the more you train on the
better so like if your test set becomes
the train set that's that's the ideal
thing
but but yeah in terms of competitive
programming I think it requires some
like advances in in data efficiency
because right now the amount of tokens
of this type of task is like less than a
billion definitely like which means that
if we follow the scaling gloves it's
it's not going to improve much by the
way Simon is the author of long llama
that came out a few days ago so do check
it out if you're interested in lava
models scaling to really long texts
thank you
[Music]
why are large language models bad at
numerical reasoning so one of the things
that I'm hypothesizing just by looking
at this little part of the table is that
the the bigger the parameters the more
complex reasoning you're living so
I think it's the same as if you were
asking maybe it's a bit trivial to say
that but if you were asking a complex
math question to a six-year-old they
wouldn't be able to do it but the more
they used to kind of like seeing maps
and doing more they do they're able to
perform more mathematical mathematically
complex one and it might be to do with
parameters it might be to do with
encoding and tokenization
um but I mean the real answer is I don't
know that's why I'm doing this one what
is the importance of tokenization yeah
so for example when I when I started
this work I used just BP or somewhere
whatever the tokenization was and the
results were just really bad and when I
changed to digit level tokenization so I
just take my digits I just use the
embedding for that individual business
and then I put it together
um concatenate them in a certain way it
does a lot better
um so in terms of just doing that little
bit of digital tokenization made a
massive impact so working more on how to
aggregate them how to introduce some
positional
um embeddings within those within those
digits that's more that's more encoding
or you know I might need to tokenize it
and uh you know token as a decimal
separately and have like the the 1000
decimals the ones before the decimals
and the decimal point separately
since L M's are bad with adding numbers
for examples there are papers that let
language models call tools to solve
numerical problems why not use that so
exactly and that's exactly what these
API calls and Tool papers do but yeah
but why I'm actually looking at is I'm
not looking at creating a math solver
what I'm looking at I'm looking to
understand how these models can improve
their numerical reasoning because if I'm
just generating text I'm not doing
anything I'm not doing any math I'm just
generating text and if I'm General I'm
saying okay generate some tag and it's
going oh um I live in a one meter Square
house that's ludicrous right so the the
the number understanding of it of just
I'm generating a story and it's giving
me some like numbers I just oh I went
out with uh 25 friends to the cinema
it's like well like is that really
closer for you that you you want you
want something maybe yes yeah yeah yeah
true I don't think I can find 25 friends
to actually go to the cinema with but uh
but yeah it's more about understand
getting these models to do the maths
um in in a and understand numbers in a
more holistic way like we do as humans
because even as humans if you tell me
I'll multiply these two numbers like
that I wouldn't be able to do it I
wouldn't be the calculator right and I
completely agree with that part of it
but as a holistic thing do they
understand numbers and which numbers so
maybe I'm working with models that are
working with the biodomain and I want I
want these decimal place to be good I
don't care about the rest of it but I
wanted that sort to be relatively good
at decimal or maybe I'm working with the
financial sector and I'm on these uh
large numbers to be good but maybe the
decimals it doesn't so if you get one of
the decimal places wrong
[Music]
why should we pre-train on Downstream
data I mean it sounds intuitive that
training on Downstream data should
improve performance but here you are
saying one can forget the usual huge
corpora for pre-training and do the mass
language modeling objective on
Downstream data instead yeah I guess the
difference in this case is that we are
not starting off of the base of like uh
pre-training of like Wikipedia or
something so like typically uh that's
something called tap which has been uh
addressed in like prior work so like you
have a model which already pre-trained
on lots of data so it already knows like
has a lot of Knowledge from there and
then you additionally add this second
step of pre-training where you
specialize it on your Downstream like
text basically not just not the labels
just the text on label text and that
helps and that has been known for a
while what we're saying is that if you
skip this step entirely the first one
where you don't use Wikipedia at all it
would still like give you some benefit
like I guess the reason why it's
surprising is because the same text is
uh used and fine tuning as well as free
training yeah so the interesting part is
that there is something special about
the master language modeling objective
or even a slightly more complicated
pre-training objectives are there in
Electra we just allow you to get more
juice out of the same data
foreign
like What's the progress in vision and
language right now because you have a
poster on measuring the progress and
find great vision and language
understanding like what what do we say
to it what's we say we need to improve
fine grain understanding of these models
like you show in your paper last year
this mother struggled a lot with fine
grain understanding but frankly
understand is is precise understanding
between image and textualities so
something like I don't know verb
understanding where
giving a caption it says a woman line
with a dog given two images both
representing women and dogs
the mother needs to correctly decide
which images represent this caption
based on the difference which
semantically is just a verb
and so if you look at the performance of
reads and models they still perform much
worse on these kind of tasks than they
do in coarse grain tasks like image text
retrieval or Downstream tasks like
visual question answer
so I guess when the information is
obvious then the model is kind of get it
but the question is how like how can we
improve this there's GPT 4 just you know
by scaling everything up is a promising
approach or to think that we need
something else and just data and scaling
and images and captions right so I think
getting the model size is something that
helps unfortunately the better lesson
scaling the data on the other hand might
not be the only thing you need but is it
because the data is just boring images
and captions are usually the captions of
images are like basically totally
unvaried and boring so maybe if we could
include more interesting text that is
attached more Loosely to the image then
maybe that would help I think it's
important like what we say like here is
that you need to have
precise descriptions of regions of the
image
so if you captions are like you know
describing what's silent in the image
and this might be very high level
but if you have specific understanding
this can help a lot
foreign
is a language model a language model so
canonically by by Shannon's 1949
definition a language model should be a
distribution over the set of finite
strings but they can uh but people
usually the fine language models through
this Alpha aggressive factorization
equation which is equation one on the
poster and that would uh that would
sometimes lead to uh the final language
model that is not a language model
meaning that it's not a distribution
over the set of finite strings because
when you when you write down your
language model like this there is a
possibility that your uh that the model
you're defining actually puts
probability on the set of infinite
strings how to decide whether we have a
language model or not oh yeah so to
answer that question we first still have
uh we have first set to uh understand
what kind of distribution that this
equation would induce uh this equation
actually induces a very special type of
uh distribution over this particular set
it's a set of finite strings the union
was a set of infinite strings because
there's a possibility that EOS is never
produced in a in a string and this
distribution would put positive
probability on on those strings yes so
this specific set is an uncomfortable
set and if you do not treat uncountable
distributions over on control cells
carefully you would end up with
paradoxes which mathematicians have been
have known since uh towards the turn of
20th century like uh during the Canter
during Canter's age or early 20th
century involving the work of the big
and um and uh Pharrell and uh their
peers yeah exactly that's the birth of
magic Theory why shouldn't NLP
researcher care whether a language model
is formerly a language model well it's
the it's kind of like the same reason as
as a well-trained mathematicians of
mathematical analysis like you don't
solve differential equations directly
with uh to have some Delta proofs but
it's one of the trainings that you have
to obtain when you're actually going to
do more advanced mathematics so if you
want to actually do if you want to
actually understand the theory behind
the NLT or NLP is mostly about
engineering but there's also some
theoretical aspects of it and if you
actually want to understand the
theoretical aspects of it it's very good
to have a solid theoretical underpinning
and Magister is part of that it's never
have it has never been put into papers
before and I feel like it's a good
opportunity to present this very
beautiful and solid formulation of magic
theory for language models in this
particular age so is jgbt a language
model why well you have to open a window
we don't know what it looks like
internally
foreign
is all you need if you have more than
enough compute to
[Music]
um
deal with the quadratic complexity that
Transformers have but if you don't then
you need different models that are
better suited to like little data and
little things right so attention is
probably all you need when you want to
train a GPT 4 size model with website
data
but for other scenarios it's not
necessarily the best one it also has
inductive biases that make it a little
more extensive in terms of data than
other models so
when we have such a scenario it's not
awful and what are the inductive biases
your of your alternative and how does
this compare to the vanilla Transformer
so
actually in our paper we try first of
all to make the inductive biases is that
MLP mixer is lacking more similar to
those of Transformers and that is by
doing weight shifts but in contrast to
Transformers we are not using attention
we're using mlts and just MLPs that was
the original idea of the local mixers
um
it's simpler conceptually and might
therefore also be more efficient in in
terms of
amount of data that you need and the
amount of fine tuning there and that's
actually what we empirically find you
said that GPT 4 like Transformers
usually don't use attention
approximations like or let's say
attention Alternatives why not like um
wouldn't it be easier to train on the
whole internet if you would be faster
why isn't open AI interested in that
that much or why aren't they applying it
um I think they are very likely applying
not vanilla attention but probably
something akin to bash attention which
is still an exact computation of the
attention but a much faster one and then
so that is something that probably
skates to 50 000 tokens or so without
too much trouble but
before that
the actual bottleneck of computation is
not so much in the attention computation
but much more in the in the feature
mixing name so it's been shown that that
is like where the majority of the
computation takes place not so much in
the attention if you go up to like 50
000 tokens or so with everything I think
that's why they are not using it yet but
they need to find a way to deal with
this eventually
okay so you don't think it's also
related to the to that winning lottery
of having one thing that works great and
doing it just because everybody else
says it didn't want to be comparable
that is we also Factor like training a
GPT for size model even with this kind
of method it's still going to be way too
expensive to just pry out but
[Music]
but I think they're two factors one
factor is like the winning lottery thing
that you just mentioned in the the other
factor is that
attention is
really robust and strong and hard to
replace with something that is linear
rather than quadratic like comparing
each token to every other token is just
a very powerful
operation I would say so it's hard to
replace it with something more efficient
why work on parsing while everybody else
is working on nlms yeah I would say that
nowadays
um there are these big language models
that are getting better and better but
we don't really have so much insight as
to how they work under the hood I mean
we know how they work on an engineering
side and making them better seems to be
more of an engineering task nowadays but
I'm more interested in actually the
underlying understanding language on the
theoretical level and then trying to
connect that to what language models do
and so there's always some some things
to be done that are more long-term than
this were you disappointed when finding
out that llms do not have any explicitly
induced linguistic information or theory
in them I I wouldn't say I was
disappointed if you have enough data
then you will find all these structures
of course you can find more than the
structures that you would normally put
in with theoretical grammars however you
have a lot of data for English language
for example you might not have as much
data for other languages there are no
research so there it might be harder to
actually do just a statistical model
that can do it perfectly and also there
are some ways of improving Motor
Performance by reintroducing a
context-free bias inductifiers into the
entity module so you can combine this
amazing statistical framework with
theoretical grammarism obviously make
things better it's not something that
you do right now in your work right yeah
I think it's interesting because now
that LGBT is making some of the research
directions that we had sort of slightly
redundant people are readjusting and
trying to find things that don't just
depend on performance but also depend on
understanding what it does and what you
can do with them so trying to find for
example humor or sarcasm or other
features that we know from a pragmatic
real-life application but actually it's
um not so clear how to make that work
with language models and statistics
because there was a keynote at this
conference about understanding versus
just repeating statistics
and I think this is on a lot of people's
minds now the question whether these
large language models can actually
understand in a meaningful way that we
would say means understanding and what
is your opinion about that
or in which Camp are you I'm in the camp
that would say there's nothing that
prevents them from understanding in the
future but currently we're not quite
there yet would you agree that large
language models understand at least at a
shallow level or do you think that the
argument llms are just statistics
excludes understanding yeah this is
really a question of the perspective
that you're taking right
um I I like the point that Jeffrey
Henson was making about
it's personal experience being just the
data that you have available to you with
an understanding is what you do with it
and so
um tattoo PT for example is not just a
language model it also has discourse
capabilities and so it also reacts to
what you're saying it's not just
predicting the next word it's actually
predicting the best answer to give this
is I would say at some shallow level
because it is working very well it's
some sort of understanding of course I
don't want to get into the philosophical
side of this and say oh is it conscious
or obviously doesn't have free will yeah
no I wouldn't I wouldn't I wouldn't say
what is the type of work presented here
at ACL that you were most excited about
yes I'm I'm always happy to see people
working on things like interpretability
trying to really understand what all
these huge recruitment models do there
have been some very interesting ways of
using mathematical formalisms to find
out
um which parts of the data is more
important for the predictions for
example and so trying to understand
these models on a deeper level using
Theory that's something I'm very excited
about on the other hand there are some
works I would say that are more on the
research on the engineering side and
that are just trying to make these
models better and better and hit higher
higher benchmarks and they're exciting
in the moment because they can do things
that other models maybe couldn't do just
before but I feel like they won't be as
interesting in 10 years time because
they they didn't make a an underlying
contribution to the foundations of the
field it's more
collecting the data cleaning the data
finding architecture training it very
well and these are important things to
be done and they're hard to do
um but they don't excite me as much as
the basic research that goes into
understanding them more then it is clear
that you are most interested in
theoretical work and you present here
some theoretical work yourself on
parsing tell us more about it yeah so
this actually spreading out of a course
a teacher's work where we're teaching
students about the beginnings of the
field of NLP and the underlying
foundations and one of these foundations
is parsing and so there are these um
parsing algorithms that are always
taught CKY early's parsing and
there's also an algorithm that parses
that tells you what the probability of a
string starting with a certain
substring is and you can use that as a
language model this is what people did
before the large language models were
around and you can you can use this to
infer a language model and predict the
next word and these algorithms they have
stood the test of time and have been
around for a long time but we found that
there's still improvements to be made
and making them faster in important ways
I would say mainly because they give you
an understanding so you can use them for
teaching but you can also combine them
with language models as I said before
and you can make language models better
potentially by using by trying to use
these grammars again so what is exactly
the complexity gain here so before we
had the length of the string and the
size of the grammar Cube
and another term that was the size of
the grammar to the power of four
we've we produced this to
the length tubes times the size of the
grammar squared as the length squared
and which is the size of the grammar
cubed which is both contained in this
first term and this other term that is
to the power of four which is quite
large uh completely disappears and the
size of the grammar is actually was
actually always the bottleneck for
parsing because if you want to parse
English language with a context for
grammar you get
an order of like twenty thousand
rules that you have to have and so this
this quickly becomes dependent on the
size of the grammar so this actually
would make it much faster what is the
key idea you apply to get performance
boost so these kinds of parsing
algorithms all depend on dynamic
programming where you trade space for
Time by Saving intermittent results
and so they already used that but we
found that if you rearrange the
equations you can make more use of that
and actually get rid of some large
complexity issues and make them much
more efficient
I was so surprised by the following
poster after so many posters on
analyzing large language models I
certainly did not expect an NLP
application to astrophysics check this
out so the main motivation is that um we
shoot more more satellites into space
and this poses some kind of problem or
some risks I don't know if everyone is
aware of space debris but basically it's
basically either on satellites or
fragments of satellites or even rocket
stages or rocket stages that fly around
Earth and
basically could endanger other
satellites or if we don't take care of
them it could even make the specific
orbit unusable for multiple Generations
of humankind right so this is a problem
not just for either but for everyone
and you can see also foreign
gets a bit of bad reputation but yeah
you can see like one example of this
problem with the Hubble Space Telescope
so there you can see it's basically hit
the solar Airway and damaged it
um it looks like a bullet yeah I mean
these things go crazy fast and all but
so it's basically has the energy of a
bullet if not even more right it just
goes through like an eyeful butter
and one problem is that space engineers
and usually not that good in database
writing database queries so we wanted to
assist them by enabling them to use a
natural language interface
for them to ask queries about the
database so they can ask a question and
then this question would be passed into
a database query and they just get the
answer
the challenges were that we didn't have
a training set available
so we had basically had to even start
from scratch or could apply some
transfer learning to make it easier
and this database is updated regularly
regularly so obviously if a new
satellite is
launched then you would also have a new
entry in the database that you have to
take into consideration
and we couldn't use an API service such
as gpt3 because Iza likes the data and
they like to keep it locally on their
system they don't like to give it to
some API you don't know where it lands
and yes proprietary stuff so we had to
develop the system
yeah yeah
exactly so there are strong regulations
with all of that so you have to have to
keep it aligned so we had to create a
kind of specialized architecture that
could run for example on the machine and
user
what would we do we applied A
specialized methodology where you have a
question
in the first step you create a sketch
which is a sequence of really basic
database operations so for example fines
would mean you find an entity in your
database such as
Space Telescope
and yeah you have multiple
um basic functions relate query
attributes so the first step is you have
this sequence of basic operations
and in the second step
you then find Arguments for
the specific functions in the sketch so
for find
for this specific question we want to
find something about Hubble you need to
find Hubble Space Telescope to query
your database
the good thing is
by
um
basically doing this two-step approach
you can first find the sequence and then
find the arguments whereas in
traditional approaches you would predict
everything together
and the problem with that is if you have
this ambiguity for example between your
question
and your arguments so for example Hubble
and Hubble Space Telescope you cannot
just rely on your system being able to
um
basically learn that or
um yeah
on fear from the question
um that you mean this argument I don't
know if that comes across clearly but
you have to think about
um
it could be anything this thing could
also just be helpless have the telescope
so you have this kind of ambiguity so
and maybe if you have like a training
set it could learn that happen means
Hubble Space Telescope but in the moment
that you update your database maybe
there's a new element that it has never
seen and then it could get confused for
example if you ask for IGS radar it's
another entity
it needs to it needs to kind of be able
to generalize
um to some degree from your question to
what is actually inside the database
yeah so the architecture
I have to say we didn't develop it
ourselves we took it from the literature
and adapted it
but what it does is you encode your
question
with a build like language model
you pass it in a gated recurrent unit a
simple decoder
and you first predict your
your basic functions your sketch
once you did that you also encode all
your entities
that you have in the database with the
same build like language model
and then in the actual prediction step
of the arguments you compare the
representation of your database entries
and the names of the entities for
example
with the representation of the decoder
at a specific time step
so you do some kind of similarity or
what is the nearest representation in
this entity space
[Music]
to go to a restaurant that everyone
understands it but you actually need to
know the restaurant's food and when
you're hungry like when I'm hungry I
want food so there's a lot of stuff we
don't say we should just leave implicit
and when arguments get more complicated
finding this implicit knowledge can be
very difficult for machines so we want
to find a method to find simplicit
Common Sense knowledge and in a
structured form so the setting is you're
given an argument with a premise and a
conclusion and the knowledge graph in
our case concept net there's like
millions of nodes and there are effects
in there like dog is distinct from cats
so just stuff that everyone knows so
common sense knowledge
um
and then we want to find a subgraph
which contains the relevant implicit
Common Sense knowledge because up here
you have like millions of nodes so we
can't use it directly here we have a
couple of nodes which we can use in the
downstream task
the way people usually do this is that
they'll find a set of entities in the
graph here show them purple and orange
and then they link them with like all
the paths up to a link for free the
problem is that you have hundreds of
parts of the length of reading content
but only a few of them make sense for
your argument
therefore we introduce a real sentence
word to compute embeddings of the
argument as well as every triplet in the
in the graph do you know Sam Pittsburgh
it's a method which you put in a sense
and you get an embedding and then you
can compute the marketing similarity
with these embeddings this allows us to
have a similarity score for every triple
in the graph which you then convert to
an edge rate and then we use this Edge
rate compute weighted shortest paths and
by doing this waiting we kind of
maximize the somatic similarity between
the path and the text so therefore also
intermediate concepts are still relevant
for the text they're like semantically
close to the text and therefore relevant
that's the idea and then we take all
these way to shortest path and we say
okay these sort of paths they form our
graph so it's kind of just the fancy
graph extraction method where you put in
a text in the knowledge graph and you
get back a smaller graph which hopefully
shows you all the knowledge that you
want
knowledge uh the task that we work on we
are working on augmentation so that's
what we did uh the task was actually
what we did in this paper
is that the task is given the premise
and the conclusion to predict how how
valid the conclusion is is it grounded
in the premise and how novel it is is it
does it bring something new because you
don't just want to paraphrase so we take
this graphs we generate them for our
whole purpose
we compute structural properties of this
graph so like how long are these graphs
how big are they what is the distance
between premise and conclusion and then
we train the classifier on these
structural properties and the idea is
that you know if the argument is very
normal if the company is very novel then
this graph will be kind of long
yes
um and we use this to train a specifier
and we perform quite well in on novelty
where's the outperformer gpt3 based
system
very simple svm I think it was in the
end this is graph extraction we can
confirm people with like you know GPD
free and really big language models uh
there's another task at semivault this
year where we use it to predict frames
and documents why care about graphs in
the era of large language models well
search CPT works on sequences so just
kind of one line of strings and graphs
are just much more General so if you can
deal with graphs you just have a bigger
tool or 10 which you can use for more
different tasks and different
applications potentially do you see
graphs as complementary to language
models uh yes I think there's just so
much unstructured text which GPT and
similar methods can use really well and
I think that's a tool that you would
want to have in the future but I think
could be well augmented with graphs
potentially for like inserting
background knowledge or even make like
the reasoning more explicit more
interpretable I think there's a lot of
avenues there to follow what are other
avenues of research at ACL that you were
really excited about so I work in
augmentation where it's you know a lot
of different stakeholders people with
different perspectives different
backgrounds and I saw quite a lot of
that at the ACL not necessarily
cognitive augmentation but just like
considering data disagreement not as a
noise in the data set but more like as a
feature of people having different
opinions and they like to see that so
it's kind of nice to see that other
people also care about people having
different opinions even it's not
augmentation directly and arguably rhf
has this effect of pushing down on some
opinions we do not want and encouraging
the ones we want yeah and a lot of
appeals in the internet are the ones you
don't necessarily want to have I think
it's also a big point of RL HF what do
you think is not represented enough at
ACL oh that's hard to say I mean
there are some ideas that I have which
were not there which is good which is
nice
I obviously think they are important
also glad that I haven't seen them
I don't know I think that's normally you
can't really say what the future will be
so I think it's good that people explore
lots of different things
um of course I wouldn't have had the
same Focus as other people but I think
that's okay and good that people do
different things
I wouldn't say that one topic is
obsolete what are best strategies to
navigate a large conference such as ACL
so do you mean in terms of like finding
the stuff you want to find or
prayer for it how to do it in real life
this was my first conference that I
attended in person so I had very little
experience
I tried to write a plan beforehand what
posters I want to attend what sessions I
want to attend
I think it was useful for me to kind of
just see what are the options but in the
end I didn't use this list I just walked
over the poster session I think I found
most of the posters I'm interested in
probably not all of them I tried to use
my list on the first day but it didn't
really work so well for me I just I
don't know it was just I need to find a
poster and you have to search for it and
it's just tedious
um yeah everything best just walk around
and see what looks interesting and talk
to people and you know just kind of
stroll around and have fun and that we
also get to meet you know interesting
people I think what would you do
differently at the next conference or
did you do everything perfectly no
definitely not but I think ironically I
would prepare myself again the same ways
I would still look what is there just to
have a grasp of what's there
um I would try to this time it didn't
really take a lot of notes during the
poster sessions and I feel like if I try
to do it now I will probably miss a lot
of stuff that happened on Monday or even
Sunday because there's been so much
going on and I think I would try to keep
more notes gradually during the
conference rather than I took pictures
of the poster so I know where I was what
was interesting but I didn't necessarily
write down why they were interesting so
I might go back to the paper look at
them which is just kind of double the
amount of work in some sense
it's actually my first in-person PC L
I've never been in one before I've been
during covet I've been to some of the
virtual ones with gather town with a
small tiny pixels so I've always wanted
to be at a conference like this to learn
see what the field is up to
um yeah yeah
a lot a lot of different things yeah
yeah you come in with like all of this
background noise of degenerative models
and what they're doing and they still
dominate there's still quite a bit of of
them around but uh I'm interested to see
you know a few different topics so
multi-modality and how that how language
models are going into multi-modality is
interesting anything around
explainability and interpreting uh
Transformers or llms is I I do find
interesting and then you find this
specific sort of problem so progress on
summarization progress on
it's a named entity recognition or like
say the other sort of specific tasks and
how people are uh
multilinguality and translation so
that's like keeping keeping on on top of
that is is very interesting for me did
you find some things that are not
exactly about llms but still interesting
well I mean there's
there's a few uh that I don't understand
very much but I'm glad people are like
researching these things so a couple of
papers on
understanding more of the topology of
embedding spaces for example so that's
very complex but um you know it's
interesting to see people doing more of
that a lot of work on robustness
evaluation is still sort of one area
where we need a lot more development so
always excited to see more and more and
better better work on on evaluation
because that's still on really an
unsolved problem like until now it's
very hard to tell how you know uh how to
compare to two different generalist
models on their use cases so
um you know that that's one area that
grabs my attention with the processors
what part of the con
es from I would say the poster sessions
for me specifically because it's like I
can grasp a lot of the information you
scan a lot and then you can exploit the
ones that interest you there's a lot of
visual explanation which is important
I'm a visual learner in a way so people
have to put some effort into put visual
EX
expression of of the poster and the
information and so that the for the way
I learn posters is a good format for the
way I I like to you know scan and go
deeper and then identify the papers and
go go read them a little bit later but
yeah other people you know some papers
surface on your radar before the
conference and you sort of go read them
um so that's part of the experience you
know when they announce the papers is
one part but then at the actual
conference for me it's posters what
would you recommend to a person that
attends a conference for the first time
ah yeah uh yeah they're a bunch I'm
still uh exploring yeah different ways
of how people but definitely a lot of
socializing a lot of going up to people
that you see online or whose work you've
but just yeah taking that initiative and
going up and speaking with people
because uh
you don't often
a lot of people aren't don't have
as much opportunities to talk with
everybody in the field like like this
when everybody sort of you know flies
down to one uh one event so just making
the most
yes that's true musician so yeah just
making the most out of making these
connections adding people on LinkedIn
and Twitter and you know building
initial threads that you follow up on
when you go back
um is something that just being distant
from the field was very difficult for me
and I see conferences make make it a
little bit easier is there anything you
would have liked to see more of I'm
disappointed in the amount of my own
personal attention and how little of it
I have given just the mountain of smart
people and smart work that's that that
comes together and like we need better
tools for let's say exploration and like
every week before one of these
conferences I'm like okay I'm gonna go
embed all the
abstracts and then explore them and have
a visualization and then identify but I
never have the time to actually do that
so I'd love for us to apply a little bit
of NLP at exploring and papers and you
know topics that you like
um to make it your compress and
summarize and sort of identify directly
that that's okay
absolutely yes
a hundred percent their view went off so
people would write a blog post here or a
blog post there maybe semantic scholar
or like somebody's like let's do it for
every conference I would I would I would
probably pay for that how did you like
Joffrey hinton's keynote uh it was it
was very interesting so I've never yeah
seen uh Professor Hinton before so just
yeah seeing him in in person
um it was
raised the discussion in this discussion
that's important for sort of the field
to have
um there are a lot of words that have
different meanings between you know
apparently different camps a lot of them
that have strong feelings about their
meaning uh of something like
that's specific towards the first part
of his talk when he was talking about do
llms understand really and there's a lot
of
um back and forth in the field about the
word understanding
um but I was always sympathetic
sympathetic to some of the examples that
he mentioned
um and given the definition of
understanding that he was sort of
outlining that it's not complete it's
just a spectrum and then might
understand some things but they don't
understand a lot of things
um but I haven't really looked into the
philosophy of both sides but uh
um and then the other side is like yeah
I've never really heard very much about
analog Computing that's the second part
um it was interesting for him to mention
he's talking about models and Ai and
then it became agents so I I'm very
interested in how llms are
Paving the way for these llm-backed
agents and I don't know if that's the
sense of the term that he he was using
the word agent in
um but the ideas of yeah distillation
and weight sharing as as mechanisms to
make these improve faster is
is another interesting takeaway for me
from from the keynote sorry that's a
long answer but it's uh yeah
you also had a Twitter thread
summarizing these points yes
that's uh I'm just yeah sharing what I
learned and some of the poster
presentations
um because yeah you leave here you
forget but if you you know write notes
or write them publicly even better
we hope you found this video interesting
and that you now have a better
impression of what happened at ACL 2023
in Toronto we leave you with some
amazing footage of the Niagara Falls see
you next time
[Music]
thank you